meow ah you got the cat box oh my I'm
sorry okay now you die
Bowser's definitely winning me over I'm
really looking forward to Jack Black is
Bowser he looks amazing I think he's
really gonna Ace the roll they pick the
perfect person for Bowser Jack Black is
transformed into Bowser so well honestly
if you didn't tell me it was Jack Black
I wouldn't know Mario because he's the
coolest
but Luigi's kind of cool too right I
mean he's afraid of ghosts wait is Mario
not afraid of ghosts no I really want to
see Anya Taylor joy as Peach because I
love her oh Peach all day love me Peach
I need to see her I grew up with her so
I'm excited to see how they took it from
the Nintendo games to a film he's
confident she's beautiful and she owns
it my real favorite character is the
mushroom because they're short and
grumpy like her
I wasn't expecting Pete to like Peach as
much as I did but honestly the lower
Voice works and you know Chris Pratt is
Chris Pratt I need you to see Rosalina
and who is Rosalina Rosalina is the
daughter of Luigi and Daisy can you tell
I stopped playing the games after Super
Nintendo my Army
whatever those things are oh
you saw Bowser a karaoke what song do
you think Bowser would just knock out of
the park I want to say Don't Stop
Believing Don't Go Breaking My Heart I'm
all out of love
don't go chasing waterfalls Dancing
Queen easy that was a quick ass you
thought about this before haven't you oh
no something by Whitney Houston I feel
like he has a Soulful side you think
Bowser wants to dance with somebody yeah
I think I could see him really going for
it with somebody who loves him I think
I Will Always Love You by Whitney
Houston okay who is Bowser singing I
will always love you too I think it's
Peach
anything by the weekend would be amazing
a Beyonce song Because Beyonce has like
these big performances it has to be
Beyonce song it can't be like a Chill
song has to be Beyonce AC DC or
something like that ACDC Wrecking Ball
by Miley Cyrus oh that's good can you
give us a couple bars
no you can though a game is like a
wrecking ball you're supposed to back me
up
[Music]
foreign
here at CityWalk they turned off the
fountains and so I can
they didn't
they didn't turn the fountains off did
they took off at any minute
[Music]
The Last of Us on HBO it's not really a
movie but it's a very good show I'll say
more to combat for 1995. it's not really
a deep cut but Silent Hill Uncharted was
pretty good there you go Uncharted I
like Uncharted it's got to be Sonic the
Hedgehog probably the sequel love it how
we finally get to see tails and we got
Idris Elba playing the voice as knuckles
dang how about 1993's Super Mario
Brothers
we don't talk about that one I was old
enough to remember the original Mario
movie and realizing like this looks
nothing like I remember like what the
heck can you guess what the 1993 Super
Mario Brothers film is on Rotten
Tomatoes Tomato Meter zero give it some
credit it's got Dennis Hopper in it I
want to get more in depth about your
love for the original 1993 Super Mario
Brothers movie that's 29 of the Tomato
Meter apparently it put off a lot of
fans not you though I just love John
Leguizamo so anything that he's in I'm
I'm a fan of it's just nostalgic it was
pretty bad but it's like when you watch
stuff when you're small or you're little
you just love it and it kind of sticks
with you even as an adult when you're
like ah my judgment's a little better at
this point you know we were kids we love
movies kids love terrible movies
everybody knows this that's right it's
so funny hearing Kristen and James's
adults say that they love the 93 version
think about it and then say well we were
kids we didn't know any better okay so
the Super Mario Brothers movie is soon
upon us but until that comes out we can
all agree the best video game movie of
all time is still 1990 is Mortal Kombat
right yes
yes that is amazing
probably with Mario Kart Mario Kart 8
All Stars I had to be Super Mario 3.
Super Mario Deluxe on the Game Boy Color
it is the direct Port of the NES version
it was the actual original game Super
Mario Brothers all the way back to 8-bit
just aim me in a direction and run as
fast as I can how long before you
actually figured out how to beat that
game took a long time since you couldn't
save the game so
memory cards are not a thing so oh my
gosh I think mine was Super Mario 64 and
that I played everyone since for sure
but he actually introduced me to the
gaming world I really didn't play any
video games I recently played Super
Smash Brothers and I was just like I'm
just gonna go for this and hope
everything works out and I actually did
surprisingly really well I was surprised
pat on the back to me
that's a wrap from Universal CityWalk
great answers a lot of fans really
excited about the Super Mario Brothers
movie how about you comment and let us
know what are you most excited to see in
the new flick for the whole team here
I'm Mark Ellis saying until next time
you're a big Mario fan is that right
yes
all right back to work yeah normal day
it's sitting awesome dude you're the
best thank you man I really appreciate
it Adam